good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday hope
everyone had an amazing weekend hello
jax hey clerd wow it's such a monday it
was such an eventful weekend just filled
with so many celebrations
it was the wedding weekend of the
century like every i think everyone was
at eight wedding this weekend there were
so many no no not just for you and you
know i know and you're informed
yeah insane like literally on instagram
yesterday on the plane just wedding
wedding wedding wedding wedding wedding
so i'm happy for all the happy couples
that tied the knot but you know i am
biased i'm most happy for a few special
ones yeah and dear i mean it was you
know on friday's episode i was like
gushing about the time yes i got three
hours
singing a different tune it is so
exhausting coming home from la i'm a
broken woman like it was the type of
weekend where like your feet will not be
the same for like a month you know yeah
um
but i was really really sad to miss
dana's wedding like i knew she
understood that like i had to thirst out
and i really like appreciate she didn't
even judge me for it she went she was
like i totally understand but i was
devastated to not be at the duty brown
wedding you
we missed you i know i spoke to snitch
it was so amazing like it was just such
a great weekend dana is just the best
person to have to celebrate because
she's such a great friend to everyone
and her and her now husband josh are the
most perfect compatible couple
that are that just to like celebrate
them and
dance with them and all of those things
it was
a joy a true joy and i'm just like so
emotional these days because of my
hormones and just like looking at her
like it was just making me cry like
totally i was just so happy for her like
i was just sitting at the table like i
was dancing but then you know some i
couldn't do the horror because like that
is a safety hazard 100 for a pregnant
woman yeah so like i would be sitting
out like wiping my eyes like it was just
it was a really emotional weekend but i
had so much fun it was so nice to hit
the dance floor elsie was out there mom
was like this else
we were boogieing it was really it was
just so much fun it was such a great
weekend i'm i'm so happy for our girl
and she looked oh incredible grace kelly
who no literally like i was she you know
she like never really wears a lot of
makeup and it was she looked amazing she
looked amazing the dress the hair the
makeup and she looked like herself yeah
but just so glamorous
and
it was it was beautiful her vows were
hysterical she's so funny she memorized
them she memorized the whole all of
everything she was going to say
the room was roaring with laughter you
would have loved them it was wow that's
impressive she memorized it she's a
crazy woman she's crazy yeah she's also
really smart like she has a photographic
memory right if you're a redhead you
know all these things about dana already
and
it was the ultimate dana's choice as
they say that's so cute it was so cute i
was like honestly having major fomo even
though like i was at the event of the
year like of course really missing dana
yeah it was it was really special but we
all we all want to hear about your
weekend well you know my weekend was
great like busy busy busy it was like
the busiest weekend in l.a like so many
events so many weddings and i thought i
would only be able to make it to simon's
but the timing on my on friday night i
was actually able to do simon's
rehearsal dinner welcome party it wasn't
a rehearsal dinner could welcome party
and then head to paris's neon carnival
which i didn't think i was going to be
able to go to even though i was
completely dressed inappropriately like
they how so i thought that you look it
was so funny neon theme so everyone was
wearing neon
and it was at the santa monica pier they
closed it down it was more like it was
like rave vibes diplo dj'd yeah so
everyone was like wearing like sandals
and sneakers because you had to walk up
the pier it was like a beautiful night i
was wearing my enormous platforms like i
looked like i was literally going about
mitzvah and i was just like i felt very
out of place and my feet were [ __ ]
killing me by the end of the night
because you had to like walk up the
boardwalk um but i was so glad that i
got to go to both like paris looked so
pretty and she was so happy and there
was like so many fun people there and it
was just lit like first of all i got
there late so i didn't really even have
time to experience like the fact that
she shut down the santa monica pier like
go to roller coaster there's no lines
play a game and all the game
games like you know classic carnival
games the prizes were all like paris
stuffed animals like they weren't like
dogs you would get like a stuffed paris
it was crazy it was just like really
well thought out you bring home any
prizes no i'm like i told you i didn't
have time to enjoy the carnival because
like by the time i got there was like so
late i like had to you know celebrate
the bride say hi to peeps i didn't have
time to enjoy the pier got it which was
so cool like what a cool concept you
know
um it was beautiful and simon's wedding
was just like
literally like the way you felt it
dana's like everyone was crying like
misty it was cry cry cry cry cry like
cry cry cry cry a little more like just
cry that's the best kind of wedding like
i don't know what is in the air at those
sorts of weddings but it was just it was
an emotional weekend maybe it was like a
weekend where only true lovers
got married well this is why i surmised
this was my summary like of why everyone
was so emotional like first of all like
walking down the aisle like simon was
hysterically crying like you know simon
like he doesn't cry he's serious he's so
serious but like his like phil is just
like this angel and like simon was just
crying and everyone was crying like i
can't it was like simon had to stop the
ceremony like three times to blow his
nose like it was crazy like you just
never see simon cry so i think it got
everyone like really you know hyped up
on emotions got it but also you know i
actually realized i've never been to a
gay wedding before like i think there's
just more that goes into a gay wedding
like the the couple has been through so
much to get to where they are it's just
you're already emotional like for that
reason alone
and it was just so gorgeous like you
just couldn't cry like you couldn't not
cry the ceremony was so stunning outside
perfect weather and then like as the
ceremony is about to start like just the
moon is like right above like he
couldn't make this [ __ ] up so it was
just like so gorgeous and then
simon's brother spoke and it was just he
was so emotional like he was honestly
giving me like tony robbins vibes like
he was walking around the dance floor he
didn't like even have papers and he was
everyone was crying like talking about
it was just it was beautiful like it was
such a gorgeous wedding and simon and
phil is just like a great couple and
like everyone showed up for them like
obviously it was a-list to the nines but
like it was you know simon's home
friends from canada and the kardashians
you know like it was just everyone and
he really made everyone feel like so
welcome
and it was just a crazy beautiful
stunning smart evening where i was just
like living my best life with my fellow
a-listers yeah no it seemed that way it
looked so beautiful i'm so happy for
them and it was a really great
successful weekend what can you say love
was beautiful love is beautiful it was
just sickening
sickening um kim made the funniest
speech at simon's welcome
welcome dinner yeah um
she really like is like an snl comedy
queen like i'm telling you that
experience changed her forever you think
so 100 yeah no i saw some of the
highlights like the instagram stories
and stuff and it seemed hysterical yeah
and she looked sickening she's so
tiny what did she wear saturday night i
haven't seen
a photo i saw actually saw her taking
her pics like that i know she's gonna
post like i know exactly where it was um
she looked unbelievably sickening and
gorgeous i haven't seen much i will
toilet but i loved chloe's outfit so
much let me tell you something about
chloe please do please tell me something
about her you know you think you know
like they're america's family you know
you think you know them and i'm telling
you like what you know about them from
keeping up like is exactly how they are
like kim is very serious and like so
like loyal and you know steadfast true
chloe is
my queen like you would have never
thought she was like the most famous
person in the room she stayed all night
dancing with like simon's friends
walking around with her shoes off like
having so much fun i was like i [ __ ]
love this girl courtney and travis are
this meg like
the energy in the room shifts when they
walk in like they really are like that
couple like and they are like this rock
and roll you know they were doing their
thing like foreheads touching like
they're obsessed with each other they're
so like
electric i can't even like use another
word yeah like there's just this
magnetism around them and it was and
they were like it was also travis's
birthday
so in the middle of the
like dance party the dj stopped they
brought a cake and played all the small
things like him and courtney were being
really cute and it was just like
you just can't not look at them like
they're so electric um chris of course
was there just being
the mothership that we know and love and
you're just like are obsessed with and
corey was literally the life of the
party i'm most interested in corey i
actually got to speak to corey a lot and
he is like everything you would imagine
this warms my heart yeah i love him wow
beautiful you love to hear it and
everyone just had so much fun everyone
was like really just so like happy and
celebrating simon and phil and it was
just the greatest weekend like the best
couple greatest weekend and now paying
the price for it like fully yeah no i my
body hasn't experienced a day such as
that in did you get to nap even on your
i didn't get to nap on the day of
because i was like in the bridal suite
all day but i did find about like 40
minutes of peace and quiet like on a
nice couch right before the kituba
signing perfect so i felt you know that
was my that was my moment but it was
actually such a
great getting ready like bridesmaid day
dana cultivated an amazing vibe
she had the red taylor's version on
repeat in the whole country club all day
when i pulled i
showed up at like 12 o'clock and i had
been in so much traffic and i was like
ready to vomit yeah and
all too well 10 10-minute version was
playing in the lobby and i was just like
okay it was going to be okay plus our
color was maroon for the
for the uh the dresses so our pajamas
were red so we were all like sitting in
this room it's thunderstorming outside
crazy it was yeah what's her ceremony
outside her name no no everything was
inside so it was fine but there was like
crazy hail storms all day so it's like
yeah coming down so hard we're sitting
in our red pajamas listening to red
taylor's version and like just getting
glam and eating bagels and it was like
such a nice like great vibe of the day
yeah i'm like so sad to have missed it
honestly yeah but i'm so glad you would
have loved it you're ingesting red like
you said you have a lot of thoughts and
like i'm waiting with bated breath i
need to talk about all of my red
thoughts specifically my all too well
thoughts sure um
we'll get into it in the fast five
because we have a lot of taylor news
we'll break everything down and i have
some i have just something i need to
share with the class and just get it off
my chest what no it's just about all too
well oh i thought you meant like you had
like a personal announcement i'm like
what is it no no thanks no i'm good okay
um so i think that we should jump right
if we're finished catching up you know
yeah i mean i feel like i've said all i
need to say we'll continue catching up
as we always do so much tv on last night
i didn't watch one minute of it because
i was on the plane and newark airport is
literally my nemesis like i'm [ __ ]
coming for your neck newark airport can
i tell you what was on tv last night i
only got to watch half of it potomac was
on salt lake city was on watch what
happens live adele curb succession
yellowstone how are we expected to
breathe no i know it's disgusting it's
disgusting so i watched potomac salt
lake city watch what happens live in
adel and so i'll be sharing my thoughts
that's pretty good i i did the best that
i could and brew was like living for
adult oh my god he he'd never heard such
a thing before no it's it's a once in a
lifetime kind of talent because when her
last album came out he was
just you know a twinkle in my eye oh
and
he was living for it he was like mom
this is talent i was like bruisal
i know we've been trying to tell you
this bruce
okay without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
solo stove there's nothing quite like
the feeling of gathering around a warm
fire on a cool evening and a smokeless
fire pit from solo stove makes your
outdoor moments even more memorable
because instead of having to constantly
dodge campfire fumes you can sit back
relax and actually enjoy the fire and
this year you can shop solo stove's
black friday sale early get great deals
on a solo stove fire pit from november
11th through the 18th you guys people
were quaking at our first read for solo
stove they either hadn't heard of it or
if they didn't they were so excited to
get the sale solar stove is like a
life-changing product
and ever since we started talking about
it i realized so many toasters already
have and so many are getting them now um
it's kind of like everything of the sort
because fires are amazing but they can
be really tedious like and they can have
a lot of like annoying things about them
clean up yeah those things solo stove
makes it so easy compact and also like
it makes bonfires a year-round activity
right you upgrade your backyard with a
solo stove fire pit where you can enjoy
the mesmerizing flames and all the
opportunities to create good moments and
lasting memories their fire pits are
brilliantly engineered they're made with
premium grade 304 stainless steel and a
360 degree airflow system that maximizes
efficiency while minimizing the smoke
shop their best deals of the year early
from november 11th to the 18th that's
ten dollars off if you get use the promo
code toast plus a lifetime warranty and
free 30-day returns so again get that
extra 10 off the early black friday sale
at
solostove.com and use the promo code
toast check it out uh you won't regret
it
okay first story red tv weekend taylor
swift on snl performing the 10 minute
version of all too well the short film
dropped the new music video dropped this
morning and we all had time to spend
with the album and are ready to share
some of our more thoughts so i think
let's go in order let's let's start with
the all too well short film okay i need
to start with this because i've had a
revelation when she first said you know
she was doing the short film it's sadie
sank and dylan o'brien sadie sync
immediately reminds me of the book that
we read for the redheads called my dark
vanessa okay because she was my casting
choice it's like a young redheaded girl
okay so i just had that in my head okay
and then i watched the all too well
music video and you know how you say
seven husbands of evelyn hugo is like
[ __ ] problems
my dark vanessa is always all too well
even though the song came out before yes
no no i'm not saying and then also the
author of my dark vanessa posted this
whole thing her stories
um talking about how when she first
heard all too well back in the day like
she perceived it as a story about trauma
and then watching the video like
my dark vanessa is an extreme version
of this of the story of all too well
because in my dark vanessa it's um
like a high school student and her
teacher got it so it it's a much wider
age gap but it's like this same
dynamic age gap dynamic and i just can't
and then i was like researching and
stuff like on twitter and seeing what
the fans were saying and like all too
well is mine or vanessa got it and i
would employ everyone to read the book
because it's one of the best books that
i read last year except i would issue an
extreme trigger warning extreme like
sexual assault grooming etc
so i was just really in it the short
film was amazing
unbelievably sync is a star okay it was
literally the sadie sync show like she
first of all is so gorgeous so gorgeous
so unique looking you know like
all these girls in hollywood i think
like are starting to morph into one
another like we all look the same
lol
that was just like a freudian slip sorry
um she's so unique looking she's so
talented i mean the crying it was really
such a gorgeous film like i could have
watched 30 more minutes of it i watched
it a hundred times like you could feel
the palpability of the toxicity like
yeah you could feel it all the ending
was so taylor you know seeing taylor
with red hair like a gas no and then the
ending where she's the uh writing a book
called odds well like that book is my
dark vanessa well the book is the song
but yes the book is the song but like
it's my dark vanessa i'm just there's
just so many parallels it's great like
just it's crazy no i know i mean
it's just been like a wild weekend and
to be kicked off with that it was i just
i can't say enough good things about it
first of all the vibes like the autumnal
vibes upstate like were just giving me
life that make out moment between dylan
o'brien and sadie was just like there
were so many no but like the main one in
the beginning with like the 360 camera
like yes steamy when he dropped her hand
at the dinner party like i audibly gasp
it was just a really good retelling of
what happened and in the song like it's
the story of this weekend upstate i
think they stayed at maggie gyllenhaal's
house she lost her virginity um
and that was it like you know i feel
like i was there i i completely get it i
hate jake gyllenhaal just i hate
and you know what like it is just
crazy that he's literally dating a 25
year old and he's been dating her for
three years yeah well i was talking to
snitch last night and she was like well
don't you think it's like sucks for jake
gyllenhaal that like all of a sudden
like this thing that this one
relationship from 10 years ago is now
resurfacing and like he's the villain
again and i'm like i feel like taylor
doesn't mind casting him in that light
right now because like the behavior
never changed and he's still dating
actually i mean yes his girlfriend now
is 25 but the map is larger and they met
when he was when she was 22. but he's 40
she's 15.
she's 15 oh my god no she's 25. there's
15 years between yeah when it was taylor
and jake it was 10 years yeah so it's
it's just even crazy and i don't think
she minds just casting like a little bit
of a spotlight on like on the weird sort
of behavior no
we've also
and i feel like it keeps coming up in
hollywood in hollywood and
it's gross yeah 100 it's so gross
no yeah i don't feel bad about it at all
like he is very much a villain of this
story and you know what when the album
came out like taylor obviously wasn't as
big of a star she is now um i don't feel
like there was a lot of pressure put on
jake and i'm so glad you know i can't
thank scott borchetta enough because
him selling her music without her
permission like got us here now we're
having this important conversation and
when red came out i listened to it
backwards and forwards backwards and
forwards all day like i remember where
in my life i was etcetera and i didn't
even know the jake gyllenhallness and
even i didn't know about like all this
scarf stuff like oh yeah scarf stuff is
like it's developed over the years yes
it has developed over the years but like
all of these i don't
i couldn't have been a bigger fan of the
album and i didn't even know all like i
didn't even know jake gyllenhaal was
like the first love of person right the
spotlight is really on him now whereas
when the album came out it's like oh
this is this is the album jake
gyllenhaal just like the last one was
joe jonas or john mayer it wasn't like
this one is not like the others so two
things one when i got to the wedding i
was sitting um next to my friend keith
and he told me that he saw maggie
gyllenhaal that day and i was like so
mad that i didn't hang out with him
because i literally would have went up
to her first would you have no of course
i would have taken a picture left um
but it also makes me think have you have
you seen this john mayer dm going around
yeah he responded to one person he
responded to a swifty he was like i hope
you choke and he was like i'm just
curious you know sorry i'm answering but
like do you actually want me to die and
she was like oh man
like i'm such a loser um and then she
wrote like just want to let you know
like it's gonna get worse for you when
speak now taylor's version comes out and
john saw it and didn't respond like they
were having a conversation and then he
didn't respond to that um but it is
gonna be a thing again with john mayer
like john mayer is very much gonna be
going through what jade gyllenhaal's
going through because that song dear
john is just as bad if not worse taylor
was 19. i forgot how old he was but i
think he she feels like he you know took
advantage of her kind of like
ghosted her it's going to be very much
the same energy for john mayer i'm
curious to see if it if this like the
energy will be kept up for john mayer i
know i just feel like the energy is so
strong on this one because of the short
film that you told us it's spelled quite
a picture quite a picture and also a
10-minute version of a breakup song yeah
no way by the way the 10 minute version
is
everything okay so let's talk about snl
has given me so much
so on the plane yesterday i had
succession downloaded and all too well
10 minute version that's about an hour
and 10 minutes of content and the flight
is five hours i watched i swear to god
just on loop this performance i was in
office i cried the first time i was
watching it could have been the plane
but i just really felt like it needed
deserved a tear
what first of all she looks so good like
i love her with bangs and i just think
like i hope she keeps i know they're
bangs for the for the red era but like i
hope she was having bangs with folklore
and everything side bangs like she
didn't have like the straight like
really early 2000s fringe yeah
obsessed okay the performance was so
stunning first of all it is so hard to
sing for 10 minutes like without getting
out of breath she sounded amazing the
guitar playing the dancing the hair
flips the
so many subtle little set things you
know talking about the
autumn leaves falling down like pieces
into place some leaves started to fall
from the sky did you see that winded my
hair a fan started to play and blow her
hair
first fall of snow
at the end of the the new lyrics started
to snow on the stage a gorgeous scene
was set with the film playing in the
background i can't even put into words
like why i was so moved by the
performance but it was just like
gorgeous and like love her just
like everyone in the world plays two
songs on snl like she's just not yeah no
it was it was definitely a treat i
hadn't seen the short film before i
watched snl so i was like really focused
on looking looking at the screen that
sucks yeah but then i just went straight
to the short film which just opened up
my my mind so
it was a good experience nonetheless but
i've listened to the song so many times
throughout the weekend just because of
like it was on repeat in the bridal
suite
and it's so good and it's i can't get it
out of my head no and now that we've
been given like so much content i can't
even listen to the song like if i'm
listening to it i have to either watch a
short film or watch snl perform it's
like i need to be further stimulated
because i know that like visual aids
exist you know yeah agreed
so the new music video came out this
morning i haven't had i'm still
processing all too well so i am not
ready for it okay maybe you can share of
course you saw first of all the bonus
songs are so good like i would say that
the best bonus songs are think about me
with chris stapleton which is what the
music video was this morning
message in a bottle
is like it's giving carly rae jepsen
like and you could really tell like she
did write it in 2010 because that's like
so the vibe
um the music video obviously starring
miles teller and kelly teller and
directed by blake lively was amazing
what song is it for think about me the
chris stapleton one
[Music]
and so just premise is obviously like
miles teller's getting married to kelly
but he can't stop thinking about taylor
and taylor shows up at the wedding like
in these looks jackie like you will die
and slowly she starts like paint the
entire wedding red it's like really
smart and well thought out like live
they did a great job like it was
gorgeously done it's like this expensive
wedding she's wearing a wedding dress at
one point like taylor's like it was so
just i was so distracted by her beauty
like she's a gorgeous but this is the
best she's ever looked yes she looks
amazing what a great casting okay i need
to i need to prepare myself no i was
like shook like him and like
they didn't kiss obviously but like
miles and taylor like dancing touching
foreheads like it was giving me life did
miles and kelly kiss no the whole point
was like he wasn't like not interested
in kelly
no i know which was like hella
disrespectful margot texts me she's like
was that not weird i'm like they're
acting but like it is yeah yeah but it's
also just like it's an honor you know an
honor to be cast 100 it was a beautiful
music video that song is so good chris
stapleton was not in the music video
which i was like kind of hoping for
um
but nonetheless i have to watch it again
like there was so much grandiose beauty
like there was this gorgeous wedding i
didn't even get a chance to dissect it
in the way that i need to i only watched
it once before this morning because i
had to talk about it here today got it
okay cool i'm really excited to have
that waiting for me and i'm not gonna
lie like when taylor announced red i was
like so i'm so dying for 1989 like i was
disappointed for sure like and i just i
take back everything i ever said because
this these last three days have been
like some of the best of my life
musically like you know they've been
they've also just been some of the best
of life period and like i think red
coming out on this universal wedding
weekend was just starting perfect 100
perfectly timed um
also just quickly about snl so i did
watch i had the episode downloaded and
like i actually couldn't finish it uh i
didn't even try it i didn't try to start
it's so like it's
so they hired those three guys they're
not cast mates but they do like a video
every season i mean every episode do you
know what i'm talking about no so they
had a video go viral on tick tock at the
beginning of the pandemic they're like
these three guys i cannot remember what
they're they're not the new featured
cast mates no hold on let me just
they're not the new like
no okay just give me one second okay
taylor's nation posted them um
i'm sorry like people probably know what
i'm talking about and like want to kill
me i've never even heard of this
okay just give me a second
what the [ __ ] are their names
hang on
i bet you think oh here okay
they are please don't destroy
they're like this trio you know these
guys
so they do a video and it's not live
they do like a com one of uh like a
recorded skit oh dude they did the um
hard seltzer one yes okay so for him
yeah for him so their three guys i i
don't know if they started on tick tock
but they had huge success on tic toc
during the pandemic and then snl like
eventually hired them to make a video
per episode they're not in okay that's a
sketchy concept yeah and they're like
the best thing on snl right now like
every one of their videos just like hit
their their skit was the one with pete
davidson and taylor like it was
obviously the only one people are
talking about and i just feel like they
need to lean into this more because snl
is like it's really atrocious got it i
didn't know that that's what those guys
were doing there yeah they're great cool
they're like a little trio who like make
videos and i was like oh good for snl
finally like knowing like having a good
idea yeah and so they hired them but
they don't use them enough like they're
hilarious yeah
so i forget what point i was making but
i just wanted to shout them out do you
enjoy the sketch with taylor swift and
pete davidson i did like it was stupid
but taylor was just like being gorgeous
giving us life and like i was live you
know
and she was being like very sexy you
know she's not really like that like at
all she's very like kid-friendly
conservative queen
um but she was wearing this like little
sparkly number and she was like being
like a sexy pop star like dancing on all
the cans it was actually crazy wow yeah
i didn't even hear about the premise
body rolls like lip touching like it was
very provocative very not taylor oh i
gotta go watch it yeah i mean the show
the episode was absolutely trash yeah no
not the episode just the sketch no
except there was one thing on weekend
update that new girl sarah i want to say
her name is sherman i'm sorry if that's
not correct she like had a moment and
like she bought herself like five years
on snl it was amazing she being she was
being herself like colin jose was like
let's talk to you cassidy like see how
it's going and she was being so crazy
and so funny like
it was like showcasing all of her strong
suits she like read everything perfectly
she didn't like stutter over the
the lines she was amazing like i feel
like she's like probably on a high right
now because like it's all people are
talking about because episode was trash
oh that is so funny okay maybe i'll
check that out i was happy for her okay
let's get into our next story the other
musical event of the weekend
adele adele one night only last night
cbs oprah
the griffith observatory and every
a-lister you could possibly think that
was surprising like the audience just
being filled with like drake leonardo
dicaprio selena gomez lizzo oprah
obviously yeah no like every time they
showed a group of people like there was
like a celebrity and friends like nicole
richie was there melissa mccarthy like
so cool it just went on and on james
corden obviously had to present himself
they're really good friends though did
he was he like a part of him no no he
was just sitting here we just got like
some face time i think ellen was there
yeah i heard she was too um so it's like
it was it was a really cool star-studded
event and it was really like you can't
just like be a thirst monster and and
make your way into this thing like i
think you had to like you have to be the
friend of adele or like a serious
a-lister so that was cool i liked that a
little part of it yeah she sat down with
oprah for an interview interspersed
between old songs new songs
she's talking about her divorce she's
talking about her new lease on life and
her weight loss she's been through her
weight loss her new relationship she
said it's the first time she's ever
loved herself in a relationship and that
you know bodes well for
that's really what they say you can't
love someone else until you love
yourself i also heard like when she met
her boyfriend for the first time it was
a business meeting she thought it was a
business meeting and i'm telling you
like these things can get confusing
especially when you're all in the
industry so i think one of the most not
polarizing but talked about moments was
when her and oprah were going back and
forth about her weight loss and how
there's been like a really negative
reaction to it on social media and just
like for fans like there's been like
backlash which is stupid um and i think
she had such a unique kind of like
brazen answer because in this day and
age like you don't say [ __ ] like that
but it actually really appreciated her
directness can you read exactly what she
said yeah wait let me pull it up um
actually i know where it is if you want
to do it yeah just because i have read
the quotes about her relationship okay
so
basically oprah was relating to her own
story like over the years you know
oprah's lost
a ton of weight um and she also gets
like backlash for it over the years so
she brought it up to adele
and adele's answer was this
sorry give me one second
take your time uh here she said i was
bozzy pop
nope that wasn't it sorry she was bozzy
paws
adele said i was body positive then and
i'm body positive now it's not my job to
validate how people feel about their
bodies i feel bad but i feel bad that
it's made anyone feel horrible about
themselves but that's not my job adele
on some fans negative reaction to her
weight loss which i thought was really
interesting because first of all yeah
like the fact that anyone even wants to
form an opinion on whether adele gains
or loses weight is like beyond stupid
like
can like celebrities have anything like
they can't even like control what they
put in their mouths like without someone
having something to say about it and two
it's this larger conversation about like
role models and i think a lot of people
were talking about it like with khloe
kardashian um
because
like setting the beauty standard yada
yada what it's like
it's not fair to put that on one person
like okay like if you
want to you know find confidence in
yourself and adele you know who you
think looks similar to you
has confidence in herself like that
gives that's lovely but it's also not
adele's job
to make sure that you can feel good
about yourself it's just not fair to put
that on one person she's like oh i could
barely get my life together i can't help
other people definitely i mean i think
it's uh you know of course it's
frustrating for celebrities they can't
like
change something about themselves or
live their lives without us talking
about it but like that's part of being a
celebrity so to have someone like lose
about 100 pounds like of course there's
going to be talk about it the fact that
the talk could be like negative and like
you left us or or like people being
upset is is so silly so i'm really glad
her take was just like i don't have time
for this but i do and she really didn't
like breathe like
foreign artist they could make this
their whole thing mission statement like
you know
taking down the haters right like
obviously oprah had to ask the question
because it's something so many people
are talking about but adele was
literally like
i did what i did yeah and she's not
explaining what i said she's not
explaining she's not explaining it yeah
no i will say like as a chubby girl
myself like i do and by the way i
totally get it like when there's like a
someone who gets famous
at like the weight that they were at and
then they lose weight there's always
like a little bit of like oh come on
like be that with us you know
but i would never like
say that you know like it's like
obviously disappointing but i don't
think they're a bad person ever if adele
feels great she looks great she's
healthy like amazing yeah like of course
now i'm like no like come on yeah no but
that's just not her job and like no it's
just gotta live her life 100 and i
support totally so i i don't agree with
people who have negative reactions like
i feel like you know yeah yeah just keep
that [ __ ] to yourself yeah of course you
know i think that's the the moral of the
story um but she looked amazing she was
singing the hits she gave us amazing
some new songs as well hold on um wine
love is a game
get over myself something like that um
they were all so good just so adele and
it was really a beautiful evening it was
making me think like what other artists
no they're gonna do something like this
and just like command
i'm going to say something crazy i don't
i've never been to the griffith
observatory i only know it from la la
land but then also the couple that got
engaged did you see that i saw that
someone got a gauge yeah oh my god i it
was it was really cute because she was
singing to make you feel my love so
that's the love song that's the song
that plays at weddings there aren't that
many adele songs that play at weddings
because they're all breakup songs and
this guy had brought his girl friend for
a picnic down in the park like below on
the bottom of the mountain and then he
blindfolded her and put on
noise-canceling earphones and brought
her up to the griffith
observatory by the time she took it all
off he's standing there proposing and
there is an audience that's a shame
you can't see adele you just it look
feels like she's on like some sort of
sound stage and there's like an audience
and her boyfriend's proposing and it's
like so overwhelming i'm so overwhelmed
for this yeah that's a sensory overload
then adele
i'm so [ __ ] overwhelmed for this girl
then she starts looking at the she goes
to take her seat she's going to enjoy
the rest of the whole mother who's
sitting around sitting next to her
melissa mccarthy gives her a glass of
champagne i am just like this is
too much this girl's going to go into
shock
it was too much and it's like she also
just got engaged she's protects her
friends and family
and then she's at an adele concert right
and she's like it's it was the craziest
that's insane i've never like i was like
having an out of body experience for her
that is
actually crazy it was too much i feel
like someone could have had like like i
would have gotten about a heart attack
yeah no i would have gotten into shock
yeah there is such thing as too much
surprise 100 i was too much of a good
thing i was so overwhelmed but back to
what you were saying because no one knew
that this adele thing was happening or
because it was like a secret concert it
was like where all these people came out
for my engagement like that's insane
but really quickly like back to what you
were saying about like no other artist
i really feel like everything adele does
is like so elevated so classy like you
can't even compare it to any other
artist
she's like really this is gonna sound
crazy but like the frank sinatra of our
generation it was giving like sinatra oh
hollywood glamour like
she she is that i'm telling you no i
agree i had the same thought i will say
that the whole you know i would give the
whole evening like a 99 out of 100 and
what's the one from the one is because
it really should have been at buckingham
palace totally and
that's just something i have to live
with i mean if you never told me that
that was a rumor going around it would
have been 100 out of 100 i just want to
say jumaa has since posted saying like
the rumor is still very much
at play and that it might be taylor
swift who who did it somebody did record
something at buckingham palace it just
wasn't adele okay and then my other
thought and
about buckingham palace and it was an
oprah sunday night extravaganza
i was like where are harry and megan
like they're they
should have been there yeah you know
because it was like the creme de la
creme yep
and they're a friend of oprah's and like
philip vanello they did the last sunday
night and it was just like they should
have passed the baton yeah and they're
british yeah well he's british and she's
british yeah so i was just like i wonder
if they didn't get the invite you know i
liked the concept of the whole
thing that they did for adele because i
think what a lot of people who just
listen to adele's music and like don't
know her really is she's very funny like
super super funny and if you go to her
concert she talks a lot between the
songs and she's hysterical so
i loved that she was able to showcase
all of her talents yes it was a great
forum it was a great way to spend a
sunday night it was just a great piece
of content we don't get really good
stuff most of the time no even though
recently it seems like we've been
getting a lot we have been getting a lot
this time of year like we're spoiled run
we are kelly clarkson is a special any
live is happening like you guys can live
please it's all happening i've
definitely lost my job to be for any
live yeah but now like my schwa to be
for annie live is like in the joke of it
you know of course yes and then of
course like when the time comes like
we're gonna have a ball a ball like a
live streaming party like it's gonna be
hysterical yeah so i'm just i'm excited
to be part of something last night felt
like we were a part of something and i'm
so happy for adele and i know what
you're such a private person still you
know we don't know what happened like in
her marriage but she said that she was
miserable like not happy in her life
didn't feel like she was living life
and she needed to become like a happier
better version of herself ultimately
like so her son could know her right as
that person and but then she also said
her and her like she said that her
ex-husband simon like that he saved her
life that if it wasn't like for him
coming in at the time that he did that
perhaps she could have gotten like
carried away with the fame and success
and gone down a different path a more
destructive path and so she's so
grateful for him she said he's her best
friend should we trust him with her life
he lives across the street from everyone
yeah no it's like
no bad blood so i don't i mean maybe
they're like things happen but there
she only had like really nice things to
say about him
she just wasn't happy in her
relationship with him okay i mean that's
great for the kid that's ideal i just
i'm shocked no it was shocking because
at first i was like
oh he's like the bit like we weren't
even saying his name i was like you know
right you shall not be named what did he
do right and no they actually are really
good co-parents well that makes me feel
good because she did give him 70 million
dollars so if you hate someone like
that's so painful that hurts but to know
like you love this man you still respect
him he's the father of your child you're
happy to give him the seven years you
were happy for the time that you spent
with him like that's great yeah no so it
for such a private person we got a
glimpse into what she's been
dealing with still not like we could get
with other celebrities where we like
know what color underwear you're wearing
every day but uh it was cool to see our
girl like you know she doesn't
share much yeah she does it so
that's great
um the rest of today's episode is
brought to you by better help is there
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals well better help us
here and they will assess you with your
needs match you with your own licensed
professional therapist where you can
start communicating in under 48 hours it
is not a crisis line and it's not
self-help better help is professional
therapy and it's all done securely
online where you can log into your
account anytime send a message to your
therapist and you get a timely and
thoughtful response plus you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do
with traditional therapy betterhelp is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available
so we have a special offer for the
morning toast listeners if you want to
get 10 off your first month go to
betterhelp.com toast and join the over 2
million people who have taken charge of
their mental health that's
betterhelp.com toast better h-e-l-p-com
toast thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our next story another musical queen
britney spears is free of her for
conservatorship
after 13 years of living under a
conservatorship the 39 year old pop icon
has been granted her independence la
superior court judge brenda penny world
friday that the conservatorship that has
controlled the pop icons life for the
last 13 years should be terminated judge
penny agreed that the arrangement should
end without spears having to undergo
additional mental evaluations
but the current conservator of the
singer's estate will continue to work to
settle the ongoing financial concerns
related to the case this is so crazy
brittany headline brittany has been
freed hashtag freed brittany freed so
you know what when i saw this like
obviously i was so happy for her but it
really kind of put into like cuz i'm
thinking like how did we get here
what's so crazy about this whole
movement is that like literally it was
done by her fans like
i don't know if there wasn't this
movement wouldn't exist without like
britney's fans and without like the
pressure that they put on they all went
to every hearing standing outside the
court like i don't think we would have
gotten this result and it definitely
were in this time frame it wouldn't have
happened as fast as it happened yeah so
i just think that's like i think there's
so much that's so toxic about like
fandoms and like celebrity culture but
like this is like
such like a good example of like
it working for good you know yes i agree
i'm so excited to see what she does now
i hope that she has the time of her life
yeah does everything that she ever
wanted to do and
i whatever's next for her whether it's
music whether it's just like vacation
whether it's babies like living in life
i think she's probably gonna like take
major time off like vacationing i think
she's gonna get married like i think
she's just
needs to adjust to like being able to
like
live with free will
um and i really hope there's some sort
of book or
movie that she sanctions that she writes
she's involved with that tells the story
of what actually happened because i'm
sure there's so much that went on behind
closed doors like we can't even imagine
yeah
agreed so so happy for her so happy some
great news and it's so nice to see
literally everyone celebrating
posting their pictures lady gaga posted
something so nice donatello versace like
literally everyone just posted like
everyone's just so team britney over the
last few months we've had these like
small wins that like we're just like
sell like you know whether it was james
off or like we're and we're celebrating
like all these things and like now it's
just it's all it's the big win yeah you
know
and we can put like this behind us well
i'm like so curious what happens now
like with her family like that's where
i'm like i have the most curiosity well
that's on that's brittany's choice yeah
but i think she's made it like
abundantly clear like she doesn't [ __ ]
with any of them yeah but you never know
yes time heals all wounds i guess yeah
these are tough these are
like gaseous big-ass movies yeah okay
are you ready for next story some more
happy news yeah taylor lautner is
engaged to his longtime girlfriend
taylor dome
making her the next taylor taylor
lautner first of all taylor schrecker
posted the funniest instagram story
taylor strecker and taylor donahue got
engaged on the same day that like two
years ago 11 11 11 that taylor lautner
and taylor dome got engaged so 11 11 is
a big day for taylor's it's also like
the red tv day you know yeah but it's
also make a wish day and
he said just like that all of my wishes
came true by the way i saw the funniest
tick tock it was like how taylor lautner
is sleeping knowing that the only song
about him back to december is actually
an apology to him like he's gonna get
when when speak now comes out like
everyone's gonna be team taylor lautner
whereas like every album so far is like
annihilating joe jonas annihilating jake
gyllenhaal we're definitely going to be
annihilating uh john mayer at some point
and perhaps harry styles so harry styles
i've been trying to think of all of her
relationships and like who were the
standouts because
let's just go album by album red was
you know so funny red is mostly jake
gyllenhaal but it's also a lot of connor
kennedy but i think like when when you
see what she went through with jake
gyllenhaal you're not really curious as
to why she dated someone like
not that famous and younger yes she
needed to be in control it's called
you know u-turn yeah right she made a
k-turn
so that's red i think obviously fearless
is joe jonas um but again whatever joe
jonas did to her like wasn't
it was just like he was just like a bad
boyfriend he wasn't a bad person where
it's like with the jig chill and all
stuff like the gas lighting the age
that's actually a lot deeper the dishes
the dishes and that's why i love the
fact that sophie and joe like are just
riding with taylor like they came to see
her at snl like yes iconic really cute
oh yeah and so did selena gomez who's
like my new favorite person jackie did
you see the picture she was also at
adele did you see the picture of her
walking into the adele thing with a bat
with a purse and sticking out of her
purse was three snickers
obsessed like i can't believe i used to
i used to like really clown on selena
gomez like i take back everything i said
i'm so obsessed with everything she's
been giving like her obsession with
taylor only murders only murders
obsessed rare beauty like everywhere
everything is so good okay wait i have a
list of of her ex-boyfriends i'll start
with joe jonas okay
then lucas till who was in the you
belong with me yeah yeah that's like a
few days they say like some fearless
[ __ ] is about him but like it's not
important okay taylor lautner back to
december mm-hmm and the movie
valentine's day yes
john mayer
obviously they say dear john ours
superman story wait slow down hold on
hold on say it again
dear john yeah obviously ours oh my god
i like the gap between your teeth does
john mayer have a gap in his teeth on my
way to find out
john mayer i used to sing that song to
peter krause tooth gap and i like the
gap between your teeth
i like the riddles that you speak okay
oh actually that makes sense any snide
remarks from my father about your
tattoos will be ignored
you could say my heart is yours i think
maybe on the bottom row but he smiles
hiding in the bottom row pretty little
okay that's a mystery i'll i need to do
some
okay i need to get some
okay back to the list ours superman
okay
i actually by the way superman is
obviously about john mayer because
everyone says ben looks like john mayer
and ben also looks like superman i think
that's like the point that they all look
like like clark kent right yeah yeah
everything about me the story of us well
i never really thought about who the
story of us was about but i actually
think that's incorrect but and i knew
you were trouble
oh
just something to think about yeah i i
thought i knew you were trouble was
about harry styles
next corey monty
yeah so actually
yes and people are now really
speculating about some of the vault
songs on red that might be about cory
monteith okay and this um
taylorswiftfandom.com
says that they dated for less than a
month you know it was like a very like
small blimp on her radar but i think it
was still like a very meaningful
relationship okay next adam young not an
ex he's from owl city yes enchanted
enchanted which is the most beautiful
love song and wait this
article says she never dated him
although he did state his interest in
her did you see you know that when she
released this song he found out it was
about him taylor wrote she met the lead
singer of owl city wrote the song
enchanted because she was just so like
mesmerized by him they never dated she
just like had a night where she was like
obsessed with him and wrote this most
gorgeous song when he found out he was
so honored he recorded his own version
of enchanted and was like i was
enchanted to meet
taylor and she and jackie nope she
ghosted him
she never responded it's horrible it was
the most crazy
i think he did actually write another
song about taylor but like taylor kind
of made the first move and then he like
embarrassed himself and shut the bed and
she like ran away shot the bed
okay next jake gyllenhaal
did you know that he reportedly spent
160 000 to have her flown over on a
private jet for a date to wear i don't
know that's what the fandom says tell us
the phantom.com yeah it must be true and
so we are never ever getting back
together yeah state of grace all too
well state of grace
okay
the moment i knew yeah and also begin
again no they didn't say begin again on
a wednesday okay i'm gonna stop singing
sorry next connor kennedy yeah begin
again
no way that's wrong
this is the fandom says starlight and
then starlight was written about his
grandparents yeah
harry styles style obviously out of the
woods and style yes also rumored that
wonderland may be about him wonderland
is about diana agron
okay she has an alice tattoo alice in
wonderland like it's obviously about
time negron okay
calvin harris oh yeah it's just so crazy
because at the time it was like her most
serious relationship and now it's like
oh they they didn't even know each other
i forgot that you were not literally
yeah it's like a joke yeah it's a joke
um i did something bad and getaway car
are rumored to be about him
well getaway car is about
three people it's about tom hiddleston
calvin harris
is it and taylor got it and also uh
i forgot that you existed really got off
unscathed well yeah
in terms of songs in terms of songs
because she skipped that album no but
also because like he didn't do anything
to her he was like nice and he liked her
and they wore that shirt he did whatever
she says
he was like literally a mule but there's
got to be a song about that too if she
could write a song about meeting adam
young right right right she can write
something oh the way she felt when he
wore that shirt totally was she pro
shirt 100 100
um
so it's just really interesting i don't
know how who out of all these guys i
would say was like the
you know
the one that got away or something but
now it's becoming clear like jake
gyllenhaal so much more than i than i
thought he was and it's also crazy
because the relationship only lasted
three months but it was like so toxic
but like calvin harris lasted like a
year and it meant nothing and we like
don't even she doesn't even like
claim him right yeah right yeah so it's
just funny and i remember when tom
hiddleston and her started dating and
was like i thought these two are gonna
get mad i thought that they were a match
made in heaven and then poof broke up
yeah well you know what it is like can
you imagine just like hooking up with
someone but it's like
you're such a star like it becomes the
biggest deal in the world so we
associated with a relationship and it's
like maybe you hung out with this person
three times yeah no but like tom
hiddleston calvin harris like those were
months no tom hiddleston was not months
tom hiddleston was like a month really
yes
like he literally i remember there was
so much hype he like went back to
australia wherever he lives he was in an
apartment building he went out for a run
there was like fans and cameras and he
spoke to the camera crew and literally
tailored him the next day
she's so funny like it's so funny yeah
okay well our fifth and final story is a
little more romance news okay lindsay
lohan and court overstreet are totally
in love in a new netflix christmas film
you guys this was the news that i did
not know i needed after hiatus the 35
year old actress will be glowing joining
glee star quarterback
because of glee gliding
i love to glow it
sorry okay and adele's bossy pasty
wow your memory is so good i it took me
a few seconds yes this pregnancy right
it feels real yeah
after a hiatus the 35 year old will be
joining glee star court over street in
the brand new netflix rom-com set for
release next year what
next year oh well i guess it's in
november but like january or like july
like it's holiday
it's gotta be and we have promo pics
already this can't be waiting till what
are what next this is your post
i don't believe it i believe that this
is coming out this holiday season and if
it's not just like don't talk to me no
totally what a [ __ ] waste yeah i do
have to say like the netflix is you know
spin on hallmark holiday movies like are
not great
it's not their best thing
so we're at a weird point here's
something weird happened you know
because hallmark was doing it better
than anyone and then everyone copied
copied them and instead of rising to the
occasion hallmark kind of just was like
no we're gonna make them shittier okay
no i disagree no we're gonna make them
faster we're gonna make them you know in
literally 90 degrees like we're gonna
make one a week like and i feel like
the hallmark quality like went down just
as its popu popularity was rising no i
feel like
the quality
went up on netflix and everywhere else
but it like doesn't have that hallmark
heart no they need to merge because what
one has the other doesn't yeah you know
they use the same coat in every hallmark
movie like get a new [ __ ] coat
the budget is like ten dollars yeah but
that's what it's always been like no i
loved it
the quality has changed remember when we
were interviewing
always like mindless
christmas mindless christmas
festivus
festivities like the mindlessness has
gone to new lows or do you think like
maybe you've just evolved no i don't
think so
i don't i actually don't think so okay i
think that they just like started
turning them out faster harder more and
like it's
they lost some that spark honestly it's
a hallmark movie about a company that
got too greedy and so the ceo leaves the
big city yeah he has to go find
a christmas spirit again yeah owens
talking to the ceo would not be a woman
sorry
him not her
had to go find the christmas spirit to
take back to corporate headquarters that
the movies could have quality once again
100
i love that but i will be watching
lindsay lohan and cordova street of
course for sure of course that has the
makings of like success what was that
chord over street movie we watched the
one with olivia culpo oh yes i think it
was called the one with olivia culpo it
was and by the way it was called like
swingerville like swinging just go with
like they like made dog clothing
where did we watch it were we in utah no
i had you guys over for a watch party
because we were like so excited to watch
olivia culpo on the big screen um i
actually got to watch olivia culpo in
real life this weekend can i just say
she's a queen amongst queens i saw her
out on the dance floor in like the
background of someone's video and she
was just like everything actually like
couldn't talk to her it was like
annoying because she's so [ __ ]
beautiful but she's literally like the
nicest girl like
i'm just like obsessed yeah it's the
movie was called the swing of things oh
you were right
i had the vibe that was the last thing i
saw cordova street in obviously before
glee
yeah no i'm i'm here for for all of it
okay well this is the olivia culpo in
the christmas movie yes give the girl
constantly um we're going to go a little
into tv recap which is brought to you by
pendulum
the science is clear a healthy gut
microbiome with good bacteria that helps
that help our bodies process food is key
to a healthy lifestyle but now we're
learning about the connection between
your gut microbiome health and type 2
diabetes pendulum glucose control is the
first and only probiotic that's
diagnosed to manage a1c and blood
glucose levels through the health of
your microbiome over time people with
type 2 diabetes lose the gut bacteria
that help digest fiber and manage our
blood glucose levels and so for those
with type 2 diabetes diet and exercise
alone are often not enough to manage it
the best approach is to emphasize diet
exercise and a healthy gut microbiome
the connection has been widely
recognized by leading scientists
studying diabetes
pendulum's team of scientists scientists
doctors and innovators isolated the
unique strains of beneficial gut
bacteria that help people with type 2
diabetes manage their blood sugar levels
they've isolated one keystone strain
that is now available for purchase
pendulum is the only place to find this
highly sought after strain take control
of your glucose levels today try
pendulum glucose control for 90 days and
if you're not satisfied with your levels
you'll get your money back that's
pendulumlife.com to find out more and
use the promo code tmt for 20 off your
first bottle of membership again that is
p-n-d-u-l-u-m-l-i-f-e
dot com pendulum life.com promo code tmt
as in the morning toast
awesome okay so first real housewives of
potomac which was really completely
overshadowed by all of the other
programming from last night uh we had
some like key arguments some key moments
there was a bit of a rep her shema but
no nicki minaj no making noise she's on
par four and last night was part two so
oh my gosh next week is the husband
everybody just like don't get too
excited okay
karen and gisele had a lovely moment you
know i'm like ready for them to bury the
hatchet and when karen
saw giselle
i saw her like what how karen feels is
how i feel and what they were saying was
like they were trying to get through to
candace like
you are going to a place that is
unacceptable
karen and giselle shade each other for
six years now they they cut each other
pretty deep but they don't go to the
bone
and
you are passing that line like
so she obviously did not receive any of
this no so i was like really starting to
become more keen on giselle
when in part one she was like
trying to
tell candace like you're the problem
here like and so i'm i'm very open to
giselle yeah no i was very open andy
asked them to say one nice thing about
each other and they were really gushing
it wasn't like a painful like
you're nice yeah it was like
giselle was actually got emotional she
was like um she said to karen that karen
was so nice to her girls when she came
to the house and that meant so much to
giselle because like she'd be just like
she popped up oh my god she was like
emotional and karen was saying that
gisele is an amazing mother and it was
really so beautiful of course like annie
has to ruin it by saying will you give
each other a hug like no i don't need
and i didn't need garcelle and rena to
hug i do not need karen they're not
children that's what you do like when
you're in the playground and you slap
someone 100 it makes it like so phony
and it's like we're not we're really not
there yet so like everything about this
was genuine until i had to get up and
give you a hug i just want to say like
if there is a world in which karen and
giselle can not only coexist but like
join forces like that is an unstoppable
duo and it's just so crazy how i am
really you know housewives is always a
journey and one week you're with someone
in the next and
how i'm i'm turning a corner on gisele
yes because like karen gave me the okay
also robin
also robin
the way that robin like reacts
physically and and uh verbally to
everyone he says like is how i feel and
wendy who at the beginning of the season
was our champion
is probably my lvp right now she's
[ __ ] the bed for sure she is
the lvp of the reunion like she just is
that lisa vanderpump or at least
valuable player the least valuable
player you never know you you it could
be one in the scene sometimes yeah no
she's
it's just not it for me like the energy
she's not giving what she thinks it's
giving not at all it's giving cringe and
i think she thinks it's giving like
serve you know yeah it's not it's giving
like painfully cringe-worthy someone
asked one of the viewer questions was if
she rehearses her duck career yes and
she would and she like even went into
like another one rehearsed
rehearse read
cause she was like i take on the white
house press tech like god
she's getting worse and worse and they
were saying the girls were trying to
explain to her how she's so different
from the season before like i'm sorry
you know what now that i'm anti-webby
like she is she is because she was like
well i went toe-to-toe with ashley that
first time at like monique's lake house
and they were like yeah but what you
were saying was like you were telling
her to call you a doctor now it's like
tick-tock the clock
no it's true
it was it was just so crazy how like in
some instances like i'm i'm all
like with someone and then other times
like i'm really the only person i agree
with all the time is karen so no potomac
is a really interesting franchise in the
sense that i don't have like deep rooted
loyalty like i'm a fair weather fan like
i'll go with like it really does change
every season where it's like certain
franchises like new york like if i hate
you i hate you if i like you i like you
and i'll defend you even if you're wrong
yeah but i really find myself in potomac
like just siding with who's ever right
in the moment yeah yeah and i think
that's also just a hallmark of being a
newer franchise yeah maybe i would say
i'm getting to a point where like karen
can do no wrong in my eyes i agree and
that's just you know having seen her do
so much right over the last six years
yeah so that is what it is she's earned
her stripes i also love ashley darby but
you know i always have obsessed also i
feel that way about salt lake city like
i'm i don't have like deep rooted stamp
every week it's like i like lisa i hate
lisa like me too the way that i'm
feeling about like last season i just
felt like lisa was all wrong and the
reunion i've never seen a more wrong
person go so hard whitney heather bad
weather spin the truth destroy i've
never seen
a more wrong person go so hard on being
wrong you have to respect like her
literally not backing down and being so
wrong but this season she's at the top
for me and i can't i can't even explain
why we need to talk about okay so then
salt lake city was on after potomac
anyways it was a good episode a little
frustrating i felt like you know
this is still not getting it
oh potomac potomac it was slow sorry but
you know it's it's still good reunion
stuff and next week should we go with
the husbands and then nikki will come
and say this husbands do really bring it
like they're they're like remind me of
jersey like they really elevate the show
yeah yeah so it'll be good now
salt lake city was what andy called like
top five episodes of housewives and it
really
was so interesting like just to watch
them
first they they jen like the swat team
leaves and they decide they're still
gonna go to please don't spoil it like i
really want to watch it
okay but i will i did see a few clips
and what's with meredith in the bathtub
so meredith she's acting weird she's
acting weird but like so here's what i
think first of all she's
had her you know eyes on jen for a while
like
she never fully forgave her obviously
she's the type of person that's like you
can't just like say whatever the [ __ ]
you want and i'm gonna like accept you
back like heather yeah just because i
want to be your friend or we're on a
show together like meredith is like a
very much a real person so i think that
you know to her this feels like karma
but in the previews for next week's
episode meredith says that she hired a
private investigator so i think that she
hired a private investigator that day or
before jen got arrested like it was just
a preview okay so my theory is that um
based on some of the things that had
happened with jen that meredith shares
in last night's episode that i won't
spoil for you that she hired a private
investigator to see what was going on
and
all of this found its way to her you
know this wasn't new information so when
she is in the bath just like relishing
injustice being served she literally has
a glass of champagne behind her like it
was definitely you know not the way that
everyone else was reacting because no
and it makes it seem like she did call
the vets like
but like that's just really not how it
works like you don't just snap your
fingers in homeland security in the nypd
show no i agree i actually don't think
it had anything to do with heather like
everyone's like who took them off that
we were at beauty lab the way that they
wound up picking up jen was from a ping
on her phone they tracked her down on
the side of the road so they were
tracking her like this is if you've seen
like any once they start you know have a
warrant to like they'll find you they'll
find it they don't need [ __ ] lisa
barlow to tell you where they are right
so
i don't think that that i don't think
any of the women were working with
neither any sort of officials but i do
think they the ones who have their own
suspicions like we're doing their own
research like whitney is pretty
up on what jen's business was and she's
the one in the in the car explaining to
everyone what she thought she did but
what she actually does so the thing is
is i watched some clips of heather on
watch robin's live and i have to say
like i'm so
done with heather and like i was so
obsessed beyond relief
when andy was like do you think she did
it first of all it's not do you think
this isn't like
you know you're on trial it's the fbi
like you did it you know yeah no last
night's episode of watch what up inside
was really disappointing and i you know
it's the biggest episode that we've had
in so long if anything they chose
heather to be the spokesperson for salt
lake city and michael rappaport was
there who's always has great takes and i
just like it wasn't giving me anything
and i was thinking to myself because
heather was saying like she wants to be
a good friend to jen
you don't kick a friend while they're
down and i was thinking about that and i
was thinking if this were one of my
friends who were going through this
how would i react
and because i'm friends with people
because i i love them and i trust them
and i
know think that they're good people i
would not be able to believe what i was
hearing right therefore i would probably
stand by them until it until i had it it
was unavoidable until i had to face the
facts but jen has never been that friend
to you no she's been only really
quite awful this isn't like
the jen who you thought was like the
best sweetest nice person ever heather's
desperation for jen's friendship has
always been like really losing and
apparent and now that no one else wants
to be friends with jen heather's like
great i can be the number one friend and
it makes heather look like such a loser
and i like have no respect for it i
really don't so watch what happens live
was so disappointing
the takes were all all off and they were
just like focusing on even michael
rappaport like come on yeah you're like
always crazy like say what we're all
thinking and i like michael rappaport so
much he it didn't strike anything
they were focusing on the dumbest [ __ ]
like how they all like jen like they
start to drive and jen had brought
snacks and left them on the car and they
just like got into them
it was like yeah dad they're snacks
sitting there this girl's not coming
jesus the snacks aren't illegal she's in
jail yeah right and we're on halfway to
vail did we ever get a gen shot mug shot
i don't know i feel like we didn't
i i don't think i've seen i haven't seen
anything
so anyways watching all the women like
it was very much like a a cycle of
emotions people are saying that like
lisa's acting weird i don't think that
like that she might
somehow
have something to do with something
because she called like her six
attorneys
i just think she likes to be well
informed yeah and like i'm not like
she's like a gentleman and also when
they first like when they're in the car
first jen like they're the feds are
looking for her and they told the girls
you know we want to make sure jen's okay
so they're just like believing
everything that they're hearing
eventually you know they get the right
they see what we saw jen has been
arrested for fraud ir taps whatever yeah
and
heather and lisa start crying and they
they're like i feel so bad i feel so bad
for her family they're so upset by the
news they like so it's
it's really like a site like you know
it's a cycle of emotions for sure
processing everything so that's why it's
really interesting i mean jenny who has
absolutely no relationship with jen
probably is representative of how most
people feel right and between jenny and
whitney like they are able to piece
together have a good understanding of
what's actually going on that's good
meredith has the best understanding
because i think she's been looking into
this
and um she's also just you know smart
cookie yeah but like mary's reaction was
also really surprising because they are
not friends and like she was devastated
like oh to hear this just devastated
like it's shocking yeah so
it and and now they're in veil right
it's like a fabulous place to be the
house is sick i would love to be there
let's go once again like the vibes of
salt lake city giving us everything
immaculate
and it's really
just we're off to the races it's crazy
because i i had almost forgotten that
all this happened and now we're it's
like day one all over again no i'm very
much looking forward to reliving it and
looking forward to justice being sorry
and understanding more even though i
feel like we have a pretty good
understanding i like the business yeah
and
i don't know if there's a way out for
genji i mean i don't know every time we
go through one of these things like with
erica i'm like there's no way out this
is gonna be here last season like you
know what she's gonna be fine i know but
it's like erica is code shot in this
situation
right no like and the coach
is actually like pretty irrelevant i
think but also he's not the one on
television in terms of all of the kind
of
criminal things we've seen on
house lives this has got to be the worst
because it's her it's her it's like what
tom did was worse like it's both ripping
off vulnerable people stealing but
erica's husband jen was the ceo yes like
i think this is the worst one and i
think if there's ever a time where
a housewife should be fired it should be
gen shaw yeah
yeah
so we shall see anyways crazy night of
television have to do the other half
tonight crazy episode i mean crazy
morning shows episode i'm exhausted so
much there was so much to get off our
chest we also just have like a busy day
like meetings photo shoots podcasts like
we're just the busiest day that hasn't
even started yet i know so we are gonna
go but we hope you guys enjoyed today's
episode we're obviously back tomorrow
and thank you so much for listening to
the morning shows millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast life
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found
so it's spotify itunes stitcher public
radio i have radio cats box all the
places so i will listen to a podcast
find out somebody just leave a five star
view about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are
and
if you're still listening
congratulations you made it to the end
of this episode you are true toaster and
you start from emoji yeah please go drop
the scarf from our channel is that what
you were going to say no i didn't i
hadn't thought about it yet like it
literally comes to me the second i say
i wouldn't know that because you're
always so prepared no literally never
think about it so yes let's leave the
red scarf on our most recent instagram
[ __ ] jake gyllenhaal have a great day
bye